and I wouldn't get the guns out I said
they said once a mate I said tell them
we made my eyebrow now and I pulled up
he's pulled an Hatchet out of his coat
and well I don't care because I've got
sore enough under mine anyway we chopped
it home is that right I went I'll blow
your your nail off and how about that
I grew up in Islington it was a really
poor area pool at the time you know and
you know we were Street kids really my
dad was a builder at his own Building
Company so it was quite affluent that
way there was no racism you know you had
black people living there you had
Muslims you had all sorts of people
living there
one thing we all had in common we were
skin so all the front doors was open we
weren't never going to steal off each
other because none of us had anything
but you could go into someone's house
and if they're having a meal you could
sit down at their table and they'd feed
you so everyone was an Auntie and Uncle
what's it like your naked when I was
brought up yeah
I was brought up now
what they call an an impoverished estate
yeah Black Hill in Glasgow
and that
we used to sell them the old newspapers
well my mate Tony I think he was a
kleptomaniac he was definitely Disturbed
you know he was out and out Thief I
think he was born but we're going to
make collecting he said he's dead on the
sweet shop and uh he said to me they
throw him outside the door the
newspapers you see a funny one you laugh
at this so we get these newspapers
take them up the fish and chips up
because it was a police around a fish
and chip shop we've cut the string off
the original newspapers wrapped the fish
and chips up in them days and uh he's
clocked it they're all just they're all
today's date right so don't pay us he
said you you've nicked his eye pain yeah
now I've got yum and we're about eight
nine what year was that like nine early
at 59 yeah and I'll see this dead cat
you know all the bits have gone out of
it it was just a mummy okay on mint fry
him right so Nick and me newspaper so I
found this cat this is the counter and
gone right into his fryer is that close
the gas down any he's kind of seen my
old man screaming his shirt in an honor
in my own memory what's it all about and
the old man used to do Ben Upton
fighting on a Sunday
and it's show him off the doors they've
shared on Alden he said you've rocked
the kids of their money he said if you
use the newspapers of course he acts
right and you deep fry the cat yeah at
what age did you leave school I left
school at 15 because my dad lost his
business and so we'll let it worked
what's the truth or the math behind
you've been the UK's youngest Armed
robber no that that was true yeah I
stuck up a post office fan because they
told me it was full of purchased with
money in it but what they didn't tell me
was it already delivered the money so
now not myself right I've I've stabbed
out my name to you then right I had a
double saw enough shotgun and so like
they weren't the youngest was in Britain
and so they give me a senior detention
center for that sure what was that six
months six months was it still short
sharp yes yes no no no I've done six
months of it right yeah so I'm seeing
them all bashing each other up in it
well as soon as you went through the
doors the screws were there and they did
and they beat you wear gloves and they
beat you so straight away that told me
violence got a voice here so he was 16
17. I was 16 coming out to 17. yeah all
right so I smashed a few people up in
there and um did you find the the staff
and they were asked my letter yeah all
of them yeah and they used to you know
like this did you get the toilets called
a blushing yeah yeah another thing I did
you know just the screws in it Where'd I
used to the others the treatment they
had they used to slash this so it was
like that so you look like the Gestapo
you know I used to walk away for school
quite a lot and cry through anger uh
gone at my grant yeah and eventually on
a short revenge on the bullies uh it
came with the attention the other people
yeah namely Thompson yeah yeah that Andy
has the enemies for my enemies and I was
asked specifically yeah why are you
doing this violence yeah they couldn't
understand that it was personal it was
personal it was Revenge I don't think he
can have a billion Billy no the thing
now that's where you and I different
mine was never a Revenge no might as
well I wanted money I wanted the power I
wanted to control
this is how got involved in the
organized crime bit I said to my dad I
said the Wednesday I said what's about
this about the insurance guy he said
well if they free brick through their
Windows if the insurance jumps up no
they just don't have Union and Chinese
restaurants and all that
and you know I'm a schemer I thought
right I've got these kids and they
looked up to me because I'd been done
with guns and I was wrong well no not a
manner and when you want to earn
yourself cut liquid they went yeah I
said I want to put two bricks through to
their windows
and then when the second brick went
through I almost didn't I said look this
is terrible What's Happening Here I said
we can stop this happening you know that
so we haven't got their insurance can't
believe but Yanks when I was on their
children they said no that was extortion
but call it what you want but they never
got no more bricks through their windows
and the deal was whenever we come into
wait we get it free put a little bit on
the bill and we get the envelope and it
was sweet there was people's place to
see us because we were stopping
aggravation but I thought I'm working
for these people and I'm collecting
money for them and also when they're in
trouble they're asking me to best people
up they're driving around in nice cars
and I'm getting like 50 Quid
when you feel you're getting a reason
yes whatever is your closest position
during that period to fill in a short
you get whacked you're going to die you
never make they're going to make this
what was the thing in your mind that
said well did you have something on yet
you say
well if he's got Farm going they're gone
I'll tell you a funny story like we'd
have tried when they come on because
I've always been anti-drugs you know not
because you know I've just seen it mess
a lot of people up good people mess up
and I thought no not for me I'll run
against that and then the tribes come on
the manner you know we had all the
people smoking dope and all that I
didn't class that as drugs because they
weren't violent they was chilling out so
you know more people done violence in
drink than ever because it's taxable
you've got it in one ain't you you know
same as I do so um
you look at that and I thought no and I
come on and I've done birds with them
because when I got the chunk for the
main floor I've done birthday traders in
their Ferrero we enjoyed the the mafia
in there for doing that government
that'd be Bond Swindle so I met all
these people
and I knew they were nasty but it said
well it's right and uh Frank walked in
the pub and I'm sitting there because I
didn't drink in them days at all I'm
sitting there you see saying it back
tribes I went what
now to be honest with you then all all
the red lights went off and we ate I
thought oh hold up I'm going to get no
it's I don't come to whack me or you
know
and I wouldn't get the guns out I said
they said once a mate I said tell them
we made my eyebrow now and I pulled up
so even I want to see Bobby Cummings I
know that's probably coming so now he's
expecting a thug you know a big heavy
like a doorman he's pulled an Hatchet
out of his coat and well I don't care
because I've got sore enough under mine
and he went we took it on is that right
I went I'll blow your nail off and how
about that I went now get back in your
car get back to Gerald Street or
wherever you come I'll see you come here
again I'm going to shoot you I said no
two ways about I'm going to blow your
face off they never come back oh my
pills don't leave me well you turn your
crate
because they'll put us crazy he's a
great of all we can remember oh it was
you know that we had to laugh over it
they went that was lucky I mean what
were you told me I said that was that
was the right touch I said if they had
come we've been protecting more if it's
on the street guns going up there but
that was the first time
that if you like I didn't feel safe
I thought myself I could have been
killed here because by her by them by
ghosts yeah
they've got it they've got it you you
don't know they could have sent someone
in a pub or could have been sitting over
having me pie and mash like and they
could have walked in with well you know
it works in the back of the nut game
over but tell me about you because you
must have been there where you thought
I'm going to get one in the back of my
nut one day that was most likely to do
with police yeah they made it quite
clear uh uh you know what that says
you're little yeah yeah sort of for
someone no no no you know that's
happening Ross 12th uh 12th of December
1984 and it's a first team that I
actually thought vulnerable yeah Ryan
handcuffed first down on the floor gone
in the back of the head so the Fear Part
was never any enemies yeah to me it was
to do with certain police officers came
to arrest me they became drug dealers
they gave up the the chance in the law
enforcement yeah and and I saw them as
rival gangsters after that it's very
funny because when I was with Charlie
Richardson and Richard Craig when I went
into Parkers and he said to me the old
Bill weren't coming because they said
next football team out you know the ones
with the berries machine guns and all
that he said don't burn out the NICU
they was out to whack you he said
because the world went round didn't
because they couldn't because I was very
cunning I kept a low profile they could
never get evidence on me and I think I
got the amp I was saying they're doing
all his Banks to his Cottage I got
enough guilty on it and when we've done
it right but they tried to put it on me
and this is why I don't know if you feel
like it I can see why people today
like with all this thing going on with
the police and the corruption it's now
it's been going off the donkey's years
it's always happened but only now it's
coming to light what's bad it's really
it's not it's a Common Thread if you if
you go back
to every single mascara is just just
this case you find that the people who
have been subject yeah to miscarriage
are Justice have spent and in between 15
and 25 years old you know the same
people I know and the reason for that
being as the cops know about involved
not retired right yeah the prosecutioner
turnout and dead and these people get
thrown back on
Slaughter
and then I done the rest for armed
robbery basically I've done seven and a
half and then I've got a dozen I've done
about 13 years out of 20. I I think
collectively the first sentence I got
was the Detention Center four months
young offenders
then I get 12 months yeah and it
accelerated to 18 months adult and for
18 months I'll go to three years uh
Pakistan as they go up was in the old
Burley yeah court number one yeah the
judge exceeded these pearls yeah and the
collector they get 45 years yeah spent
year for four year eight months in the
high security Belmont
Phil Sutton Franklin Durham uh I now get
released for for the
Franklin prison in 21st of January 2002
so this is the 21st year that have been
free from prison yeah the worst thing
I've actually seen in prison was a
disembowelment a slash near the throat
did you see the sugar and the boiling up
well no tip over here no the worst the
worst thing I saw without was I was
asked recently what was my possession
yeah unpleasant
[Laughter]
it was people who wanted to do donations
yes either Sunday dinner at a dump and a
bunker yeah yeah Landing no no no no
over somebody said my job is to make it
as like Le borro or traco
whoever sat near the district dog
accidentally flashed yeah and I've seen
it done a few things oh Danny and and
the noise
that's right so the violence side there
that good screws yeah oh yeah bird
screws these good cops and backups and
you get some you get some bad prisoners
that's right but the violence that's on
there uh and you know as well as either
99 of the people
so it's a violent place for violent
people yeah but you do get and it's
important that people know this the the
prison authorities have got a friend and
four lust yeah yeah yeah yeah right but
they like playing chess with people
that's right you're dead right remove
this gang member to there now I'm just
going to kick off neither gamble yeah
they put a score do you know so they
come up in the Mubarak case where the
young king Felton got an Asian kid was
in there for 90 days and another guy
killed him with a chair leg and there
was rumors that there was a gladiator
things set up to if I put in with him
would I attack each other who would win
and I was having a bet on it so if I
went players for violent people
I respect your decision to to live that
lifestyle yeah what was your Catalyst
for doing that you can laugh all right
they open me parole and Prince I went
you having a laugh you know they come up
nice of you know go to a pro ball and
when you're having a lot I took the fit
me Governor hostage in Albany got sent
to Parker next stop is Broad war and you
want me and this is in my zone you want
me to sit down with a problem going
really a good boy now and they've got
files like that on me for what I've got
up so I'll say I ain't gonna happen fell
in love with the prison librarian right
we got married which actually had to
give her a job at yeah yeah no it's true
so if you like I was always a faith I've
even stole their library right yeah and
I've stabbed a librarian and we had a
beautiful daughter my daughter's Sophie
because I've never seen something so
beautiful in my life you know here I've
got this beautiful child and it was
turning me Paul and I thought I made a
promise to myself If Ever I had kids
they'd never seen me sitting over a
prison table where did you decide to go
straight belmarsh no come on uh 19
97 when the solicitors came and we had
the last Fast Track system getting put
in London all these boxes evidence was
here and then tons of other boxes aren't
full evidence one's a sugar grass
and I make him with attention MI5 that
were at tons of myself and my co-accused
were the first ones in the UK to be
arrested by Security Services yeah and
when you're done run a book criminality
as you know Bob yeah you never think you
come attention to these people no no and
when you come to attention when you're
on the radar yeah there's only one thing
for it yeah put your hands up give me a
sentence that's right yeah get yourself
and that to me happened in 1998. it
wasn't just because of January 21st 2002
the doors open there's this Angelic
voice to speak to you for the clouds
that you're going straight I had plenty
of time to think about it so I'd done
all the courses on Frozen and that's
what I think it's really it's relevant
there is a point in time in everybody's
life where they can pinpoint and say
that's a cat list that's right this is a
situation so Maize actually heartened
before I was even sentenced my mind was
similar to that is Charlie Richardson as
you know got me in the open University
yeah and this will promote education
because education was Liberation for me
yeah two things that done me one I
thought when I had that gun a little bit
I thought I was invincible I didn't care
people go and shoot me I'm going to
shoot you first you know I think I
didn't care about it
I really thought I was invincible until
my daughter my second daughter died
um that brought me to my nose it was
like someone punched holding my chest
and ripped me out and I didn't want to
hurt people anymore I see people there
with their little kids looking intensive
units you know where the kitties are and
I thought why not me I wouldn't wish
this on anyone and anyone who's had a
child died and says I know you feel no
no you don't it's it's too personal it's
personal when you reflect
this world you was into where the world
I'm in now
and I realized the damage I had done to
other people when I was doing it I could
justify it there I look at it and I
think some of them justify to be honest
and I feel I'm glad I've done it to be
honest with you some I think that went a
bit too far I've overreacted but when I
killed an innocent on a bit of work you
know someone got gave them choked in
their own point because something to go
wrong
and an innocent died I know I know that
story about it and I've heard that
numerous years ago that is severe uh
empathy yeah for what because it should
never have happened no no
if you look back at everything you've
been through if you could change one
thing what would that be I wouldn't be
public comments I'd hate that job
I think regrets uh
there's probably
not many that you could certainly think
about uh hindsight is disgusting I think
my bag is for great was taking all the
hassle back to my mum's house who didn't
deserve it when my mum passed away God
Rest her in 2013. the parish priest
mentioned their bedroom so it was like
the Vatican my mum would tell lies yeah
I think it
it doesn't
do other things Justice I'm sorry I've
done that no whenever no we're not sorry
no because if we were sorry we wouldn't
have done it in the first place I think
you know because we I think what what do
you have worked most of our work which
are punishment anyway that's right
that's right but I think when you said
about the parents because when I was a
kid we used to go button and Palace of
my Dad what's changing the guards and
all that and people used to be walking
through that doors going in to get their
their honors and my day went see them
they're toffs he said when you get
through that gate that's when you know
you made it now my mum and dad all
through their life just knew me as a
villain they had died
and I walked through that gate and I was
getting my IB and up like I wish she was
here to see this part one thing I've
learned now Paul the price of pace
less
you're a really sorry
led up the stairs at the back go in
there shaving at his monster sitting
behind a table with his nine mil
right and that's the opening Gambit
that's how we're going to start the
conversation him with his nine mil
pointing at me